today's new member of the day is Warren
Spiller Warren thank you for being a
david pakman show member really
appreciate your support also appreciate
the support of Moira Byrne Philbrook who
is today's longtime sustaining member of
the day with us for almost five years
Warren and Moira thank you make sure to
go to WWE at mancom to sign up coupon
code this is 20/20 we'll save you
40% I was browsing the David Pakman show
subreddit this morning at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t and saw a
couple of interesting posts that i
wanted to call to your attention one is
sort of funny but it actually is
something i've read about before a user
posted I've discovered a novel way to
fight against conservative temperaments
feed the believers shrooms I know it
sounds insane but hear me out this is
actually not as crazy as it might sound
and of course nobody that I know would
advocate the force-feeding of
psychedelic shrooms to people to try to
make them not conservative but what the
what the studies do tell us is that it
does appear as though experiences with
shrooms and some other psychedelics even
in small doses what are sometimes called
micro doses can make people
significantly more open and generally
speaking open them to more progressive
liberal ideas so is the solution to
conservatism giving everybody shrooms
maybe not in some kind of literal sense
but it's very interesting the studies
that are that are around on this now and
we actually have sort of explored this
on the bonus show in some way and even
in a couple of interviews and I don't
know if it will literally make your
evangelical gun-toting anti choice right
winger say you know what I think I'm
voting for Bernie but it does appear as
though some of these experience can
experiences can predispose you to be
more open to hearing those ideas also on
the David Pakman show
subreddit do you consider David Pakman
to be a hero
Rodie Mulligan says David is a hero for
delivered delivering the news we need
often at times at a cost to the show for
radio affiliates and offering the show
for free in addition to heavily
discounted subscriptions at a reasonable
price you know Pat I have to say I do
not see myself as a hero I am a cog in
the wheel trying to spread information
encourage critical thinking and have a
good time doing it or something like
that this would be a good time for me to
say the real heroes are X&Y although I
don't know exactly who I would say but I
see myself not as a hero whatsoever
I hope I'm inspiring the heroes I love I
love how there were dozens of reddit
posts over the past week that you could
have chosen here on this segment to talk
about but you went with this one for
some reason yes
I'm pointing out that I am no hero and
anybody who sees me that way should not
but they should just get a David Pakman
show membership and call it a day okay
support the david pakman show subreddit
by subscribing for free at david
pakman.com slash our IDI deit